a maior inspiração da humanidade é a paz
universal a união eo amor entre todos os
seres humanos em santos
se atendermos as notícias que preenchem
nas telas mas nós complicamos tudo são
cada vez mais os motivos que nos afastam
do que os rossoneri
nós construímos um mundo triste que está
a ficar feio nos hoje eu vim falar das
coisas belas trouxe uma flecha e o que
sentimos todos nós quando observamos
flores elas atrás pela sua beleza
sublime maravilha nos com as suas formas
as suas cores e usando a mais por semana
elas fazem sentir sensações de bem estar
e harmonia de beleza e alegria e já
pararam mesmo coração de lisboa na base
do parque do art 7º quando o bosque
jacarandá está todo florido que há mais
turistas a fotografar os jacarandás do
que a estátua do marquês de pombal iria
sair é um sucesso turístico durante
todos os meses do ano
e seguramente que não é por causa das
suas praias com areias brancas porque
não dá por causa das flores e da beleza
da natureza
a festa das flores ficam maiores
é um sucesso tremendo os afectos que
sentimos nas mulheres daquela vila
produzirá em folhas de papel durante
seis meses atrás naquela vila alentejana
mais 900 mil visitantes no espaço de
apenas uma semana
o mesmo podemos observar na festa dos
tablets mais nas romarias de viana do
castelo enquanto lima e em tantas terras
foi em vão com as flores por esse país
fora
temos um passado de uma história que nos
ligar flores
tivemos um milagre das rosas da rainha
santa isabel
já tivemos inclusive uma função com uma
flor como símbolo florzinha natureza
atrai anos e tem o poder de criar e o
dom de criar sedes entre os humanos
o sonho representa mas é muito simples
florir portugal flor irmos todos
portugal inteiro na sessão recomeçar com
flores nas janelas e varandas a passar
para as estradas e nas praças das nossas
aldeias - ensinados e circula hoje beira
de estradas
kan que faz a gente era linda era
possível criarmos uma ou anda em tornar
se possível nós podemos fazer e ovário a
nossa autoestima eo orgulho nacional de
criar a potência na produção e amarmos
tudo o que é português e de portugal os
nossos produtos
as nossas transições os nós que estamos
era lindo era o hino mas para tal
precisa acontecer é preciso dez anos
todas as mãos e os portugueses não se
unem assim todos nós já nos sentimos
unidos no passado descendo por duas
vezes a primeira vez foi uma vela por
cinco anos e é interessante porque nessa
altura a internet ainda não está
desenvolvida no via facebook
a segunda foi a propagação de emoções
positivas pela mão da sociedade civil em
2004 com as bandeiras pela janela
foi lindo passarmos nos meus sonhos
jogar nos com os afectos acusam de vocês
recordam seguramente do dia da final em
que a seleção saiu de alcochete e foi
até o vale do loge começou com camping e
galope cavalos lusitanos levantando a
bandeira de portugal nós vemos foram
seguidos por mera vontade e centenas de
milhar
portuguesas ao longo de todo o percurso
mas o melhor estava por brasileiros
foi na ponte vasco da gama quando
assistimos a uma quantidade de barcos e
tentar acompanhar freneticamente o o o
ritmo da seleção
esse foi o momento em que todos nós
sentimos um forte aperto no coração
sentimos sentimos os olhos a brilhar em
lágrimas
aquilo que sentimos foi amor que nos une
é sempre ia tempos que somos feitos
a alma portuguesa e agora o pessoal todo
florido a história deve ser um momento
em que muitos de vocês nesta sala devem
estar a pensar este tipo de evitar mas é
louco eu também chamou louco é que em
2004 fez o desafio para colocarmos as
bandeiras nas janelas
eu não acredito aí e confesso senti
vergonha quando sente quando conduzia
por serem as primeiras bandeiras
timidamente nas janelas
mas quando vi o meia vendas concentradas
não vou só eu comecei a acreditar e
quando entrei num táxi e perguntei ao
taxista
o porquê de ter a sua bandeirinha
portela jornal lá eu fiquei surpreendido
por foi recebido com uma resposta
carregada de efeitos sobre a nossa
bandeira e sobre o nosso peixe
nesse mesmo dia quando cheguei em casa
eu peguei meus dois filhos e foi comprar
uma bandeira para aquela janela de casa
e se em vez de bandeiras ou sem flores
uma onda de flores responsável
jamais iria tarde conseguiremos fazer
com que portugal se tornasse através da
moeda não tem isso maravilhoso de ação e
contemplação funcionar mesmo possível
floreios portugal
deus não acreditar seguramente eu não
estava aqui hoje
gostou porque acredito assim como nas
vantagens que vocês que podem advir o
futuro dos nossos filhos
há 60 anos pouco mais de 60 anos não
havia uma única árvore
a monsanto na floresta que o chamamos o
hamburgo chegou a querer é poder
assim o desafio será presente hoje não
podia ser mais simples na próxima
primavera
vemos todos por flores nossas janelas e
varandas
vamos lançar essa semente cativar quem
jogaria para colocarem também flores nas
suas janelas e vamos todos acreditar diz
que podemos fazer portugal nos jardins
guardados à beira mar plantado
sentiríamos então o país e fui cheiro em
todos os sentidos
mas o mais bonito mais interessantes
o que mais me toca e estaríamos todos a
caminhar na mesma direção da baixo da
felicidade e do amor
obrigado